[Music]
thank you i have another question
back to the question that we were
talking about the relationship between
resurrection and baptism of emergencies
we were talking about how people go into
the water that is dead and when we come
back we come back into a new life so a
question would be
yes so a question would be um does it
really matter how many times we do that
because there's a lot of people who you
know they go back to get baptized you
know
one or two times
a certain point is there a certain point
where it's like is that really enough
the bible does not tell you how many
times be baptized we know there are 12
disciples who were re-baptized by paul
in acts 19 1-7 paul met them
he asked which baptism do you receive
this said the baptism of john then they
never heard of the holy spirit because
paul said have you received the holy
spirit since he believed they said we've
never heard if there be any holy spirit
then he preached to them with the holy
spirit and they were re-baptized 12
disciples so re-baptism is biblical
evangelism page 375 ellen white writes
when a soul is truly reconverted let
that soul be re-baptized let him renew
his covenant with god and god will renew
his covenant with him reconversion must
take place in the churches and so
re-baptism is oftentimes a very
excellent decision people need to make
but i'm not saying you get re-baptized
every time you you break the sabbath or
you you know smoke a cigarette or
something i'm not saying that i'm simply
saying re-baptism is a biblical event
it's between the personal god to decide
if he or she should do it
but no outside power can determine your
conscience on that point
but you can be provided with guidance
from the leaders guidance but the
exercise of your conscience that's your
domain
but re-baptism is a biblical concept
thank you and the last question that i
have
is will we live in houses in the new
earth
well yes
if you read john 14 one to two let
nothing one to three let not your heart
be troubled you believe in god believe
also in me in my father's house on many
mansions if it were not so i would have
told you i go to prepare a place for you
a mention for you so yes what they look
like we don't know but the old testament
also tells us we shall build houses and
inhabit them so yes it will be a real
life it won't be people floating around
like clouds it will be a real
three-dimensional life the difference is
no sin
god has an entire universe to run he has
creations of whole we will help him do
that we will be busy we will live places
we'll travel differently but we will
have a real flesh and blood life
and one of the great things of the
gospel jesus will live that life with us
he will always retain his humanity he
has it now
so he will be with us he look more like
us than he look like god because god is
a spirit you don't see god you know the
way you see a human being a spirit is
not three dimensional as far as we know
a human being is so we shall live a very
very involved active busy life we shall
eat we shall drink we shall fellowship
we shall keep the sabbath we shall build
houses yes we shall do that
the thing the thing missing will be no
sin consequently we shall do it in the
very presence of god we shall walk with
angels talk with god face to face ah how
can anyone miss that
and i look forward to that oh god bless
you sister please god bless you so do i
maybe you and i can live on the same
street with sister dinosaur uh
mccurchien
yes yes yes
thank you so much
for answering
god bless god bless you
thank you god bless you too
[Music]